Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu u k w unsere kleine welt und ich hab so den eindruck,
das wandelt sich jetzt hier langsam zum krisen kanal denn wir begleiten ja hier immer dinge die onboarding sind und was könnte von going sein als derzeit die allgemeine corona krise,
und ja heute gibt es mal einen bericht von der front zumindest von einer front und begrüßt zunächst einmal die sophie hallo.
Wir sind natürlich hier aus der ferne zusammengeschaltet und ich glaube ganz deutschland lernt gerade eine ganze menge über audio setups headsets und all diese geschichten da wird sich eine menge verbessern.
Soviel du bist teil des zerrt,
das wollen wir jetzt gleich mal kurz erklären aber vielleicht sagst du erstmal selber kurz noch was zu dir was du so machst und warum du jetzt hier in dieser rolle bist.
Ja ich bin sophie vierundzwanzig jahre ich betreue tagsüber server in center und nachts kümmere ich mich um den katastrophenschutz hier im land.
Bin seit mehreren jahren teil des senats das ist das chaos bonds team die sanitäts- und brandschutztür von chaos judoclub.
Die auf den ganzen größeren und kleineren events den brandschutz und die erste hilfe auf den event sicherstellt und immer für euch da ist.
Genau das sollte man vielleicht erstmal so erläutern das zerrt ist ja wirklich eine spezielle geschichte also
für die leute die jetzt sozusagen hier unser umfeld was uns beiden ja sehr bekannt ist so nicht kennen der c computer club macht seit langer langer zeit große veranstaltungen die mittlerweile schon
sehr groß sind der kongress empfängt ende des jahres achtzehntausend leute.
Auch die autor veranstaltungen sind mit fünf sechstausend leuten auch nicht gerade klein
und es hat sich ohnehin ja dort so eine kultur durchgesetzt mit wir machen alles selber das bezieht sich natürlich auf die ganze organisation planung und durchführung aber dann eben auch in allen bereichen
auf bautechnik netzwerk natürlich keine ganze computer kam aber irgendwann kam dann aus diesem umfeld
der leute die ohnehin in so saniert als sanitäter arbeiten im rettungsdienst in krankenhäusern arbeiten aber eben auch im bereich der feuerwehr und funker auch hat sich so 'ne gruppe gefunden
die sich daneben als das chaos emergency response team zusammengefunden hat und das gibt es mittlerweile schon sehr lange ich glaube
siebenundneunzig ist das alles gestartet.
Siebenundneunzig hat angefangen und seitdem achtzehn drei haben wir uns dann das genannt.
Genau also drei ist der achtzehnte chaos comunication kongress mittlerweile sind wir beim fünfunddreißigsten angekommen die beim sechsunddreißigsten schon angekommen genau also das ganze hat so eine gewisse tradition wie groß,
ist diese community mittlerweile.
Also wir haben um die hundertvierzig helfer.
Im kern drin und wir werden natürlich auf den großen events immer wieder unterstützt durch viele andere freiwillige engel die uns da tatkräftig unter die arme greifen.
Also die freiwilligen auf dem kongress werden engel genannt und das setze ich quasi aus aus allen bereichen zusammen.
Ja also wir haben ärztinnen und ärzte pflegekräfte wir haben feuerwehrleute wasserrettung bergwacht tja im prinzip der gesamten deutschen.
Nicht nur deutsche europaweiten katastrophenschutz ist bei uns vertreten und das gesundheitswesen auch.
In welcher form ist das gesundheitswesen da vertreten.
Wir haben ärzte von unfallchirurgen über zahnärzte die wir auch zu den events mitbringen wir haben intensiv pflegekräfte wir haben normale pflegekräfte.
Die auch dabei sind wir haben rettungssanitäter notfallsanitäter.
Wir bilden im prinzip einmal den kompletten querschnitt durch die ganzen rettungs- und gesundheitserhaltung.
Und hundert diese hundertvierzig leute sind sozusagen mehr so eine kerntruppe die die immer dabei ist und die aber auch außerhalb der events in irgendeiner form zusammenhängt.
Genau wir haben einen großen streamer channel wo im prinzip fast alle helferinnen und helfer mittlerweile vernetzt sind.
Wir schreiben uns da im prinzip über die events darüber hinaus einfach informationen zusammen.
Die war einfach sammeln das ist auch ein ganz normales socialising wie man einfach in einer größeren community immer wieder hat und wir haben jetzt einfach gemerkt so.
Dass wir auch sehr viele informationen darüber sammeln können dadurch dass wir so groß sind und auch so breiten der fläche gestreut sind.
Das ist meine einschätzung richtig dass das eigentlich etwas einmaliges ist dass das sozusagen in diesen kreisen so ein überspannend community da entstanden ist über die jahre.
Als mir ist noch keine andere community untergekommen und ja ich glaube wir sind tatsächlich einmalig.
Daraus leitet sich ja dann auch immer eine gewisse schlagkräftige zeit ab also ich bin selber immer wieder sehr beeindruckt muss ich sagen was so auf den events alles so geht
ja also einerseits wie natürlich der event als solcher begleitet wird aber wir halt auch immer schnell
auf irgendwelche notlagen eingegangen wird relativ früh musste man sich schon an den gedanken gewöhnen dass wenn wir irgendwo ein outdoor festival haben dass der krankenwagen der da steht
selbstverständlich nicht nur,
für die veranstaltung zum einsatz kommt sondern wenn in der nähe irgendwo ein autobahnen unfall war oder so dann wird halt auch mal ausgerückt also sozusagen ist es immer alles im betrieb und man hat auch so den eindruck dass es es funktioniert,
auch wie so eine ja eine kombination aus krankenhaus und und und und feuerwehr stelle also wenn man da hinkommt da sitzt er nicht irgendwelche gelangweilten leute rum sondern es ist alles,
extrem organisiert sind die abläufe dort am laufen stimmt mein eindruck.
Ja also wir haben natürlich unsere hierarchische organisationsstruktur die wir einfach aufgrund der auflage wieder von behörden bekommen weil zum beispiel einen großen chaos communication kongress da ist ja auch eine,
feuerwehr vor ort also die feuerwehr leipzig grüße an die netten menschen da draußen war ja auch vor ort und hat im prinzip,
diese veranstaltung von behördlicher seite nochmal überwacht und da haben wir natürlich ganz viele auflagen die wir erfüllen müssen,
das bringt uns im chaos in so eine sonderrolle also ein chaos ist ja im prinzip erstmal alles möglich und für uns ist es halt nicht so wir haben halt auflagen die wir erfüllen müssen wir müssen zum beispiel breiten von rettungswägen einhalten,
gewisse dinge sind verboten wir rauchen im gebäude oder stoffe müssen wir bestimmte beschaffenheit haben und darauf müssen wir uns ein bisschen achten.
Weil wenn die auflage nicht eingehalten ist kann die vorhabe wiederum diese veranstaltung untersagen.
Und das wird dann auch dazu gerade auch daher dass wir aus den rettungswesen kommen dass wir sogenannte melde dich einfach einhalten sprich wir haben draußen unsere wir nennen sie das sind unsere teams aus zwei bis drei menschen die.
Draußen immer rumlaufen auf der veranstaltung ansprechpartner sind für alle teilnehmenden dort,
die melden natürlich ihre erkenntnisse und informationen an unserem sogenannten displays.
Das heißt in leipzig in der glashalle haben wir unten drin räumlichkeiten die glashalle ist dieser,
ist ein großer bauernde messe leipzig zentral gelegen und das ist unser dispatcher das sind zwei bis drei führungskräfte aus dem rettungswesen wie das alles also wie gesagt gelernt haben und,
sammeln die informationen und die weiß noch aufgaben zu wir haben zum beispiel auf dem kongress die notrufnummer eins eins zwei belegt,
und die landet dort bei uns in der nimmt dann in der anruf an und fragt dann ab was ist denn passiert und wenn es zum beispiel zum medizinische notfall ist.
Dann schickt er halt ein team aus sanitätern zu diesem notfallort hin wenn's jetzt irgendwas technisches ist ein brand oder,
irgendwie ein kabel das dose von der decke hängt dann kommt unser sogenannter techniker runner zum einsatz das sind meistens feuerwehrleute oder.
Helfer brandschutz helfer die dann sich um die technischen belange kümmern.
Und das ganze natürlich vierundzwanzig stunden am tag,
rund um die uhr immer mit schichten system et cetera also das ganze ist extrem organisiert und.
Macht aber auch spaß also es ist sozusagen man hat ja manchmal das gefühl man man über überlastet dann die leute die da im zerrt aktiv sind aber ich habe auch oft zu den eindruck dass
viele da auch so einen ganz speziellen fand rausziehen.
Ja also wir kommen aus organisationen die menschenleben retten und das ist so eine einstellung die man hat oder auch nicht hat und für uns ist das.
Nicht arbeit das ist dienst an den anderen auf diesem kongress und wir haben halt was gelernt und menschenleben zu schützen das heißt es durch medizinische technische maßnahmen.
Und das treibt uns alle an in diesem team das ist wirklich ein großartiges,
fast wie eine familie wir helfen uns gegenseitig helfen auch gerne allen anderen da draußen.
Es ist einfach schön zu sehen wenn jemand mit einem problem zu uns kommen weil er zum beispiel irgendwie zahnschmerzen hat dann kann unsere zahnarzt draufgucken und sagt hey das geht schon du brauchst dir keine sorgen machen ist zumindest diese psychische stress komponente weg.
Es gibt einfach unheimlich viel zurück.
So wenig überraschend habt ihr euch natürlich dann auch der aktuellen kronaz krise angenommen.
Wie ist das bei euch in der community eingeschlagen und was hat sich daraus ergeben.
Angefangen hat das anfang des jahres als die ersten berichte reinkamen das ist ein neuartiges virus in johann china gegeben hat mit jedem soll.
Das war am anfang eher so eine randnotiz und dann hat sich das aber über die zeit jetzt bis hin vor drei wochen ungefähr immer weiter verdichtet.
Wir hatten zum beispiel einen kollegen der für eine ngo in einem land nahen osten unterwegs ist und wer dann auch,
mehrere berichte eingehaucht bremer gruppe gesagt hey guck mal hier gibt's was neues es ist wichtig und dann hat das so ein bisschen fahrt aufgenommen.
Als dieses virus dann immer näher kam wo natürlich auch einen hilfsorganisationen.
Vorbereitungen getroffen was könnte passieren und das hat man in der bremer gruppe relativ gut gemerkt die informationen wurden immer immer mehr.
Und dann haben wir angefangen dass man so ein bisschen zu kanalisieren also wir als wir betreiben im internet.
Wo wir einfach informationen die wir aus dieser primer gruppe zu ereignissen.
Sammeln können auf einmal niederschreiben und dann hat man einfach gemerkt dass ich mir die letzten zweieinhalb wochen wie das.
Doch ziemlich viel wurde mit den informationen die wir einfach aus der breite bekommen.
Das heißt,
für viele stellt sich diese aktuelle situation auch so ein bisschen damit,
gott auf einmal sind alle total überrascht und jetzt bricht die große hektik,
aus das ist nur in teilen so es gibt durchaus gruppen die das schon so ein bisschen am kommen sehen.
Also dadurch dass wir im prinzip als helferinnen und helfer die vorbereitungsmaßnahmen als erster sehen auch vielleicht mitorganisieren.
Merkt man einfach frühzeitig irgendwas im ankommen ist wenn man halt auch wie wir den bundesweit organisiert ist sondern ich würde schon sagen weltweit.
Dann ist das einfach eine ganz andere informationslage die sich dann dort kondensiert.
Was habt ihr denn sozusagen veranlasst also was was passt was passiert jetzt im zerrt.
Wir haben dann diese informationen in das video gepackt in unserem und das wurde immer immer mehr.
Dann haben wir irgendwann gesagt hey das das kann noch niemand mehr nachvollziehen was sich jetzt geändert hat wir haben zum beispiel alle erlasse von der bundes-und länderregierungen dort gesammelt,
auch mit gültigkeit staaten mit zusammenfassung was steht denn drin und wurde sie aufgehoben oder durch einen anderen paragraphen ersetzt.
Diese wikipedia ist so groß dass sie einfach niemand mehr nachvollziehen kann auf einen blick,
das heißt wenn ich jetzt heute reingucke und morgen wieder dann kann ich maximal über die über die bearbeitung historie herausfinden was was ich jetzt geändert hat und daraufhin ist dann die idee gestanden hey wir könnten noch eine tägliche zusammenfassung schreiben was hat sich.
In dieser kroner krise von heute auf morgen verändert was ist wichtig gibt's irgendeine neue therapieempfehlung die für.
Die leute da draußen in den krankenhäusern die jeden tag im leben kämpfen unheimlich wichtig sein könnte daraus hin haben wir dann das projekt gegründet.
Oder ins leben gerufen dass einmal am tag abends diese zusammenfassung als e-mail-newsletter und als blog veröffentlicht.
Also das läuft im web unter der url punkt punkt ch,
punkt de und es quasi ein blog wo einfach immer am abend zusammengetragen wird was hat sich eigentlich seit gestern,
verändert was sind für neue informationen erlasse gemacht worden was sind für studien veröffentlicht worden etcetera p.
Wir haben mehrere bereiche wir haben einmal einen technischen bereich wo wir.
So dinge wie die eu hat vor zwei tagen dazu aufgerufen das bitte hier medizinische adapterstücks.
Sollte weil die hersteller nicht mehr schnell genug liefern können die sind auch komplett überrannt von dieser situation.
Solche sachen bringen wir einen technischen wir haben gesellschaftliches diese aktuelle locker und die wir gerade erleben ist natürlich auch psychisch und.
Physisch sehr sehr anstrengend für die menschen die das einfach nicht gewohnt sind und ich nicht kennen menschen sind soziale wesen und brauchen interaktionen die haben mir einfach in diese momentan lage nicht.
Und da haben wir dann auch einfach tipps.
Tipps wie man damit umgehen kann also wir selber bringen die tipps nicht sondern was wir machen ist wir sammeln die information wir haben zum beispiel auch eine e-mail adresse mit neunzehn punkt c punkt de wo wir auch,
meldungen von allen da draußen annehmen und wir zusammen wie wir filtern hier gucken einfach was es.
Falschmeldungen was ist wichtig und was ist auch relevant und wirklich jeden abend rausgeschickt zu werden und wenn da zum beispiel die telefon seelsorge man auftaucht dann einfach deswegen.
Um möglichkeiten aufzuzeigen wie die situation umgehen kann.
Also das polizist ist ja relativ umfangreich ne da ist ja schon angedeutet verschiedene sachen die ich greif jetzt einfach mal so dass von gestern abend mal als beispiel heraus dass
eröffnet dann erstmal mit einem längeren absatz oder längeren text zur thematik cybercrime trifft pandemien natürlich auch so eine perspektive glaube ich,
die so mit dem wissen was im zerrt ist was ja eben nicht nur sich jetzt auf die,
reine rettungs- und medizinische seite beschränkt sondern ihr seid ja eigentlich auch alle durch diese nähe zum club auch sagen wir mal der teil dieser ganzen rettungsset der auch so
auf eine besondere art und weise digital affin ist ich meine du bist ja selber das beste beispiel tagsüber.
Fixe die server und nachts die menschen so und merkt man auch gleich beim lesen dass ihr einfach ein ganz anderes grundverständnis am start ist und dass die dinge dann eben auch ganz gut zusammengebracht werden kann
nächste sektion ist medizin wo im verschiedene,
dinge gebracht werden ethische überlegungen bei kritischem verlauf in der pandemien et cetera also absolutes meter thema aktuelle lage bezüglich der intensivbetten und patienten
risiko studien verschiedene medizinische themen dann gibt es einen weiteren block rechtliches,
also wo jetzt quasi die ganzen erlasse der bundesregierung oder der länder so sie gefallen sind zusammengefasst werden und verlinkt werden.
Bereich technisches ganz interessant hier von der firma träger das sind die die diese ventilationssystem bauen.
Genau das ist.
Deutschlands größter hersteller für beatmungsgeräte und auch in der feuerwehr bekannt für die pressluft atmen das ist das atemschutzgerät das ist da auch sehr verbreitet die kam dann mal zu uns solche haben die material das,
wäre vielleicht ganz cool wenn es mal mehr medizinischer fachkreisen lesen würden.
Falls zum beispiel eine anleitung geschrieben haben wie man aus dem alles sie gerät ein langzeitbehandlung gerät machen kann und was man beachten muss.
Das haben wir natürlich dann auch veröffentlicht weil es einfach wichtig ist dass wir jetzt beatmungsgeräte schaffen können diese aktuelle situation.
Neunzehn wird hauptsächlich durch die beatmung kuriert wir brauchen nicht viel anderes sie brauchen einfach sechzehn stunden am tag beatmung in bauchlage und weitere acht stunden in rückenlage.
Und dann wird das schon das ist die therapie wie am meisten hilft momentan weil wir einfach kein medikament haben und keine info.
Hallo,
weil die leute also wenn die krankheit voll ausbricht ist halt die lunge quasi geschwächt weil unter attacke und die beatmungsgeräte helfen einem beim atmen,
so dass man dann diese phase bis das immunsystem irgendwann wieder herr der sache geworden ist überleben kann weil man ansonsten unter umständen nicht genug kraft hat das selber durchzuführen.
Dann gibt es noch einen bereich aufrufe appelle also etcetera verschiedene sachen transkript e von pressekonferenzen dann wie du es schon erwähnt hast gesellschaftliche,
dinge statements von verschiedenen gruppen,
aber dann auch noch ein bereich über die diskussion über standortdaten nutzung mobilfunk etcetera was da gerade passiert,
ein link auf diesen hecke von der gerade gelaufen ist wir versus virus wo glaube ich wesentlichen darum ging wie ich weiß nicht ob es nur darum ging aber es unter anderem ging es darum drucker systeme zum einsatz zu bringen ist das ja schon gerade erwähnt.
Es ging es ging mir darum dass man technische lösungen finden kann wie der gesellschaft und auch den medizinischen kräften die arbeit erleichtern kann.
Es wurde zum beispiel eine app ins leben gerufen das ist so eine art nina für medizinische kräfte nina ist das bevölkerungs- system des bundes das ist per app die kann sich jeder aufs telefon installieren und bekommt dann einfach.
In katastrophenlagen oder bei hochwasser eine meldung mit handlungsempfehlungen auf sein handy geschickt.
Das wurde jetzt im prinzip so ein bisschen das prinzip abgewandelt für medizinerinnen und mediziner wollt einfach informationen vom robert-koch-institut das ist die oberste deutsche behörde zu solchen bekämpfung.
Angezeigt werden sollen.
Gerade das sammeln von informationen scheint ja gerade ein echtes problem zu sein nicht also die aktualisierung der fallzahlen et cetera läuft teilweise noch über fax und telefon und es
findet nicht zur einheitlichen zeiten statt et cetera dann gibt es glaube ich eine ganze menge dinge die verbessert werden können
betrifft sicherlich nicht nur den bereich sondern ich glaube derzeit merken gerade alle mal das sozusagen unsere zögerlicher umgang mit digitalisierung uns jetzt auch teilweise ganz schön auf die füße fällt
schulen etcetera.
Wir haben halt auch in deutschland föderales system das robert-koch-institut jetzt ganz oben und die gesundheitsämtern sitzen in der melde ich hätte ganz unten.
Der katastrophenschutz hat immer was mit melde ich hatte zu tun das heißt es gibt immer ein vorgesetzten,
der entscheidet und so ein lokales gesundheitsamt sitzt in einem ort das sammelt information über die fälle die infizierten fälle in dem ort und gibt die an die nächsthöhere,
ebene weiteres ist dann meistens der kreis und der kreis gibt es weiter ins land das land sammelt das dann wieder,
gibt es nun einmal täglich weiter alles ans bunt und der bund ist halt in dem fall ist komplett koch-institut das heißt bis zu einer infektion.
Von einem ort beim robert-koch-instituts stattfindet sind dann sind sehr viele technische würde man sagen praxis dazwischen sprich,
die sammeln und geben weiter und das führt dann zu verzögerungen wir haben da vor zwei tagen am zwanzigsten dritten haben wir das backboard von der berliner morgenpost verlinkt.
Die greifen per per skript das ist im prinzip ein kleines computerprogramm auf die daten von den lokalen gesundheitsbehörden zu und sammeln die quasi direkt.
Die sind damit ein bisschen näher an der tatsächlichen infektionsbad zahl daran.
Also da sind auf jeden fall nicht nur lösungen nötig sondern es sind vor allem auch viele lösungen schon am start und um darüber einen überblick zu bekommen,
soll unter anderem eben auch dass bullitt beitragen es gibt ja außerdem zu dem bulle bulle ist jetzt sozusagen,
das tägliche change look also dort wird sozusagen gesagt so leute hier das,
das ist neu das ist alles passiert aber ihr habt ja auch noch ein öffentliches sammelbecken für all diese ganzen informationen um die übersichtlich auf einen blick zu haben das wird auf gitarre gehostet,
was zu sagen.
Genau das ist im prinzip dass es im prinzip die öffentliche kopie unsere sprich alle bereiche die nicht sensibel sind weil wir quellenschutz haben weil es,
dinge gibt mit der sperrfrist die werden kopiert im prinzip aus der wikipedia und dann oft geht hab dargestellt dass es im prinzip linkshand-bogen und es ist toll dass putin.
Ist ein bisschen challenge wir haben aber auch ein bisschen note drin also das.
Wir werden also alles was wir dort schreiben ist ja immer mit mit quellen im volltext verlinkt das heißt wir wir sammeln im prinzip die informationen suchen uns das wichtigste raus das heißt wir sitzen da abends drei bis vier stunden zusammen mit fünf bis zehn menschen,
und diskutieren darüber was ist jetzt relevant um in der person die ganz ganz vorne dabei ist in diesem kampf gegen sepanik bestmöglich zu informieren.
Das ist das projekt tor das im prinzip schreiben.
Vielleicht ein kurzer überblick was ich in dieser informationssendung also auf der einen seite unter einem link findet also ihr habt diese ganzen dashboards zum beispiel zusammengetragen also wie zum beispiel das gerade von dir erwähnte dingen der morgenpost da gibt's ja noch diverse andere.
Sachen lage informationen checklisten.
Dann medizinische informationen hier für prophylaxe maßnahmen so was weiß ich vom haus rezepte für handy desinfektionsmittel verschiedene andere dinge auch.
Also konkrete tipps sozusagen.
Genau geht dann weiter die diagnostik und die therapie von copic neunzehn beziehungsweise der saskia zwo infektion an sich also das virus das virus und die erkrankung wiederum heißt grobe neunzehn genau.
Damit ist auch klar und da sollte man vielleicht noch mal dazu sagen die von euch bereitgestellten informationen sind wenden sich jetzt primär an die.
Ich weiß nicht was ist eigentlich der richtige sammelbegriff dafür rettungszentrum klingt bisschen.
Rettungs- gesundheits- und katastrophenschutz.
Okay rettungs- gesundheitskarte strophe scholz also das was ihr quasi als community auch repräsentiert dass es eure informationen sammlung
um den gesamten deutschlandweiten oder eben auch weltweiten corpus
klar strukturierte gut zusammengetragene und permanent aktualisierte informationsquelle dazu reichen das waren einfach im zweifel dort nachschlagen kann und dort immer die aktuelle informationen findet.
Genau aber nicht nur nicht ausschließlich was wir auch eine rückmeldung bekommen ist von ganz vielen da draußen die das als primäre nachrichten überlesen das problem was wir haben ist eine info die wir haben medien die,
alles mögliche schreiben in anderen teilweise sehr überhitzten tonart.
Das macht den menschen angst wir sind an sich ist unsichtbar die erkrankung ist für viele auch noch unsichtbar weil wir.
Gibt es nicht sechzig prozent infizierte haben aber doch schon mehrere tausend mehrere zehntausend sogar und die menschen sitzen zu halten zu hause und wissen nicht was was geschieht mit ihnen und dann haben die medien.
Die alles selber jetzt darstellen und dass wir als gegenpol damit versuchen ist eine sachliche darstellung von dem was wirklich passiert.
Indem wir auch alles immer mit volltext quellen belegen.
Das bekommen wir sehr sehr oft als rückmeldung was wir auch sehr toll finden dass es nicht nur die fachgruppe liest sondern auch einfach die andere community im chaos wie zum beispiel nur.
Also sagen wir noch mal ein bisschen was zu dieser info die mir gibt's da vielleicht mal so ein zwei beispiele die euch jetzt besonders unangenehm aufgestoßen sind.
Da haben wir zum beispiel bilder aus italien das wirklich eine schlimme situation ist.
Aber nicht von dir dargelegt werden es wird nicht gesagt hey die haben einen mangel an beatmungspflege,
einfach gesagt saskia zwo neunzehn ist einfach immer tödlich und es wird auch sehr oft berichtet dass nur ältere menschen betroffen sind,
und das sagt zum beispiel die weltgesundheitsorganisation nein sie sind überdurchschnittlich betroffen im schweren verlauf.
Trotzdem haben auch jüngere menschen symptome vielleicht auch starke symptome.
Das ist ja es ist einfach dieser welt wo wir heute leben bild gewinnt man leser nur noch durch hetzer wäsche überschriften und nicht mehr durch sachliche information.
Aber hast du nicht auch den eindruck dass das sich die medien auch mühe geben.
Die geben sich mühe.
Es wurde aber viel zu lange totgeschwiegen dieses thema und jetzt sind wir quasi auch in einer gewissen in der panik machen wir haben natürlich medien die das sehr gut machen wie zum beispiel die tagesschau die auch sehr fundiert und sagt nicht berichtet.
Trotzdem ist der output aus dieser redaktion sehr sehr hoch die schlagzahl ist hoch wenn ich den tagesschau aufmacht dann habe ich alle fünf bis zehn minuten fünf neue meldungen.
Das fühlt sich so an als wenn ich in einem riesen einen reißenden strom in der wald kommt sie nicht auffrisst.
Und welchen welchen eindruck würdest du lieber vermittelt wissen.
Informierten eindruck fundierten umgang mit dieser krise einfach wir haben sehr viele aspekte die es zu beleuchten gibt.
Wir haben nicht nur diese saß an dem wir haben ein gesundheitswesen das seit jahrzehnten sagt hey wir sind überlastet aber es wird milliarden nicht wirklich aufgegriffen.
Und jetzt werden sie als helden dargestellt also diese stilisierung von schweiz tot und jetzt sind's die helden und nach der krise werden sie vermutlich wieder vergessen werden.
Das ist einfach diese diese diese medienpolitik die mir nicht gefällt.
Wie denkst du wie zu sehr überlastet ist das gesundheitssystem um jetzt mit dieser krise angemessen umzugehen.
Das gesundheitswesen herz seit jahren auf sparflamme wir haben.
Kapazitäten abgebaut wir haben krankenhäuser privatisiert die müssen jetzt gewinn machen.
Einer der größten krankenhaus betreiber helios zum beispiel schreibt jetzt hey wir brauchen geld vom bund obwohl sie.
Gewinne erwirtschaften wie es in ihrer aktionäre weitergeben also wir haben wir haben das krankenhäusern die dazu da sind menschen zu kurieren zu helfen wirtschaftsbetriebe gemacht.
Und das passt irgendwie nicht zusammen gesundheitswesen ist ein dienst an menschen die bürger wissen alle menschen und wir haben das glück dass wir möglichkeiten gefunden haben uns gegenseitig zu helfen.
Aber das durfte und dass das zoll auch keine wirtschaftlichen interessen dahinter stehen.
Und denkst so dass dass ich das jetzt in irgendeiner form kurzfristig beeinflussen lässt da ist wahrscheinlich relativ wenig zu machen also jetzt reden wir ja über eine langfristige perspektive über die krise hinaus.
Wir haben ein problem dass diese wirtschaftsbetriebe ja auch irgendwie ihre ausgaben decken müssen.
Durch diese gruppe erkrankung braucht eine sehr viele beatmungsgeräte wir brauchen intensivbetten das heißt intensiv wird da haben wir eine pflegekraft die ein bis zwei personen betreut auf normalstation sind's fünfzehn bis dreißig.
Das heißt wir brauchen sehr viel mehr personal und vielmehr gerätschaften und auch material und das kostet geld und es wird.
Für diese betriebe sehr sehr schwer das alles zu finanzieren deshalb gibt es jetzt auch nothilfen vom bund zu diesem betriebe damit sie das material überhaupt noch beschaffen können.
Das material ist eh schon klappt also wir haben durch diese hamster köpfe in den letzten tagen persönliche schutzausrüstung für die leute die da wirklich gegen das virus kämpfen und für die erkrankung da sind statt geworden das ist rationiert.
Wie kann man denn jetzt dem zerrt helfen so beim beim helfen
helfen also ihr tragt informationen zusammen jetzt vor allem ich meine es geschieht natürlich im hintergrund wahrscheinlich noch sehr viel mehr als wir jetzt hier auch nur anreißen können und wir konzentrieren uns jetzt auch gerade mal auf deinen
eigenen konkreten fokus nämlich diese ganze informations sammlung und deren veröffentlichung zu mitzugestalten,
welche unterstützung könnte das zerrt gebrauchen aus dem chaos umfeld und darüber hinaus was findet schon statt und wovon könnte es durchaus noch mehr geben.
Also ihr werdet uns unheimlich helfen wenn ihr uns informationsschild die ihr vor wichtig haltet und ganz ganz toll wäre es wenn ihr diese information vorher schon ein bisschen prüft und auch dazu schreibt mir's geprüft hat und was diese artikel den ihr uns da schickt außer,
dafür haben wir diese e-mail-adresse wir haben ja auch immer auf dem blog unten in jedem artikel drin stehen wo er uns die informationen schicken könnt.
Gleichzeitig freuen wir uns natürlich auch wenn ihr unsere managers da abonniert oder unseren blog regelmäßig isst das ist einfach ein großes dankeschön für unsere arbeit das motiviert uns.
Wir sind ja auch schon einige dabei ne also geht ganz gut weg.
Ja also wir haben siebenhundert leute auf dem wetter die uns jeden tag lesen und tausenddreihundert die unseren blog jeden tag freiwillig lesen.
Ist der newsletter und das bulli tin das selbe oder ist das noch mal was anderes.
Das ist dasselbe wir haben einfach mehrere möglichkeiten geschaffen wie man das abonnieren kann mailing ist das meistens so eine halbe stunde früher weil mit dem blog natürlich erstmal vor markieren müssen in das richtige format das ist publiziert retten kann.
Okay also man kann sich quasi an diese tägliche buletten anklinken indem man es per mail abonniert dann kriegt man es auch am schnellsten und am direktesten und direkt in die inbox,
man kann es aber auch jederzeit im web und der bulle tin zerrt c d e
anklicken man kann es im vollen feed auch abonnieren wenn man so ein vitrine benutzt und damit ist man dann sozusagen schon mal direkt am informationskrieg könnt ihr noch irgendwelche,
technischen hilfsleistungen sonst wie ressourcen brauchen in irgendeiner form oder seid ihr da gut aufgestellt.
Wir sind momentan gut aufgestellt wir haben ja seit jahren auch ein eigenes cluster wo unsere infrastruktur drauf läuft das reicht momentan noch aus.
Und wenn ihr wirklich mal die grenzen kommen werden das glaube ich einfach reinschreiben und freuen uns dann über technische unterstützung aus dem club umfeld.
Super sophie hast du noch was was du noch über das bisher gesagt hinaus noch mitteilen möchtest.
Bleibt zu hause schützt eure mitmenschen und danke an das großartige team das jeden abend diese leistung verbringt.
Okay dem schließe ich mich natürlich an ich sag vielen dank vielleicht finden wir zwischendurch auch nochmal die zeit auf die nachrichten als solche einzugehen so so du die zeit dafür findest.
Ja vielen dank sophie und vielen dank fürs zuhören hier bei ukw bald geht's wieder weiter sag tschüss und bis bald.